all right let's move on to our um
five headlines
[Music]
you know as we talk about all this news
uh by the way ben shapiro has a new book
out called how to destroy america in
three easy steps
that relates to you know everything
going on in the news uh
because it's a it's a very prescient
book the book covers
two fundamentally different visions of
america that are now on the table one
vision is unifying and finds our
unity and shared philosophy and culture
and history the other disintegrates our
country in the name of fundamental
change
how to destroy america three easy steps
details how this alternate worldview has
gained so much culture
cultural ground so quickly and i'd
really recommend the book you can pick
it up on amazon or at barnes noble
right now number one we begin with this
which
you know to my mind should be the top
headline everywhere uh it
you know it really should have been what
i started the show with and what every
show starts with
a report in the new york times about the
pentagon's ufo program
okay this is this is some pretty
incredible stuff so listen to this
says despite pentagon statements that it
disbanded it disbanded a once covert
program to investigate unidentified
flying objects
the effort remains underway renamed and
tucked inside the office of naval
intelligence
where officials continue to study study
mystifying encounters between military
pilots and unidentified aerial vehicles
pentagon officials will not discuss the
program which is not classified but
deals with classified matters
yet it appeared last month in a senate
committee report outlining
spending on the nation's intelligence
agencies for the coming year
the report said the program the
unidentified aerial phenomenon
task force was to standardize collection
and reporting on sightings of
unexplained aerial vehicles and was to
report at least some of its findings to
the public within 180 days after the
passage
of the act okay uh let me get to that
there's there's a lot of
i recommend i rarely recommend new york
times articles but this one i'll
recommend there's a lot of information
in it
uh let me get to a couple of highlights
here
for more than a decade the pentagon
program has been conducting classified
briefings for congressional committees
aerospace company executives and other
government officials according to
interviews
with program participants in some cases
earthly explanations have been found for
previously unexplained incidents
even lacking a plausible terrestrial
explanation does not make an
extraterrestrial one the most likely
astrophysicists say
mr reed harry reid the former democratic
center from nevada
who pushed for funding the earlier ufo
program when he was the majority leader
said he believed that crashes of objects
of unknown origin
may have occurred and that retrieved
materials should be studied okay now
here comes the part we should
you really need to listen to eric w
davis an astrophysicist who worked as a
subcontractor
and then a consultant for the pentagon
ufo program since 2007
said that in some cases examination of
the materials had so far failed to
determine their source and had led him
to conclude
quote we couldn't make it ourselves
mr davis who now works for the aerospace
corporation a defense contractor
said he gave a classified briefing to a
defense department agency as recently as
march about retrievals from quote
off-world vehicles not made on this
earth okay
there's the money quote right there it
only took me 15 minutes to get to it
so that is an astrophysicist who worked
for the pentagon
publicly confirming on the record to the
new york times
that they have retrieved alien
spacecraft that that's what he just said
in this new york times article that
strikes me as
like a pretty big deal
yet everyone is just like oh oh aliens
cool
aliens what else is on tv
uh there has been very little reaction
to this somehow
even though the pentagon the pentagon is
basically standing there and telling us
yes space aliens exist folks
we make a big deal out of everything
that happens in the world
except this somehow
now i i admit to that that i still have
a fair amount of skepticism even in
spite of this i fully admit that
uh because all you know all joking aside
well this isn't a joke at all but i do
have some skepticism even though i
believe that i certainly believe there
are intelligent civilizations out there
in the universe it seems almost
mathematically impossible that there
wouldn't be with a hundred billion
hundred billion galaxies and a hundred
billion stars in each of those galaxies
and you know trillions upon trillions of
planets i mean there are probably
millions of intelligent civilizations
it's just that the the distances as i've
always said the distances are so
vast that it seems likely to me that
that it's just impossible to traverse
them
or that um no civilization could advance
that far
within their technology without
destroying themselves first
kind of the cynical view but i think
there's something to that but even so
i mean this seems like a pretty big deal
anyways it's very interesting at least
and nobody cares uh but let's go number
two here
here's rather than caring about aliens
here's something that people did care
about this weekend uh
here's here's a clip that went viral
watch this
and video games are a real problem
they're real problem you know why
because they're
fun and you don't yeah well i have a
real problem with them
and you you you do them and they're real
exciting but you don't get anywhere
right it's like you could do like like
martial arts right you could learn
jiu-jitsu
you get obsessed by jiu jitsu and then
three years later
you're you're like an elite jiu jitsu
athlete you're like you're entering in
competitions you're a purple belt
you're moving up yeah you're doing well
you're thinking like i might be able to
open my own school one day that
confidence yeah if i have a hundred
students and those hundred students are
paying me x amount of dollars per month
i can make a living
holy [ __ ] i can have a this would be
amazing and then you see your jiu jitsu
school and your jiu jitsu instructor has
all these students and drives a mercedes
and he's got a nice family and like
that's the future this way you're doing
something exciting and fun and you don't
or you could just be playing video games
three years later you could be that same
kid
just playing video games waiting for the
next vics whatever the
game is you know next xbox game to come
out and you're gonna waste your time
people were extremely upset about what
you just heard there
from joe rogan because we live in a
nation of ridiculous stupid children
obviously everything joe rogan and he
admits that he's a video game addict
himself
okay everything he's saying there is
absolutely correct
he's saying that it's not good to spend
too much time playing video games
that's all pretty obvious really
undeniably true and he's saying that
you know if you look back at your life
you says three years if you've looked
back at the last three years of your
life
and you've spent hundreds of hours
playing video games
think about what else you could have
done
with those hundreds of hours
you know you could have become a jiu
jitsu master in the meantime you could
become a master of many different
disciplines and
and and and develop many different
skills
instead you just play video games and
you really didn't gain i mean
yes it's you you were able to relax
because you know that's
of course we're all just starving for uh
for relaxation and recreation right it's
not like we're
we're drowning in that stuff already but
okay it's recreation you were able to
relax you had a good time that's fine
nothing wrong with that
i don't think joe rogan is saying that
you should never play video games he's
clearly not saying that
but you don't really you don't this you
don't
you don't gain much else from it that's
you know you you look back on your life
at the end of your life and and you
think back all the time you spent
playing video games
you're probably not gonna think to
yourself that was time well spent
right um you're probably gonna think to
yourself man if i could have just carved
out like a third of that
chunk it's like not not that i never
played them but maybe just
take a third of those thousands of hours
i spent
and used it to i don't know write
write the next great american novel i
mean anything become a master chef
right learn how to like build a house
learn how to farm
anything it's like an actual physical
skill where i'm out there doing
something
i mean i think that people people
probably think that to themselves
and that's that's a pretty obvious point
now
yes anytime this comes up the gamers out
there
will point out that oh well you could
say that about about watching tv you
could say that about spending time on
the internet
absolutely you could and people do say
that all the time i mean
how often have people lamented uh all of
the the hours that americans waste
watching tv and netflix and
and you know trolling social media yes
that
that also is part of it but the thing is
you're allowed to point out that
it's probably not the most constructive
thing to spend
40 hours a week watching tv you're
allowed to point out
that if you're on facebook for six hours
a day it's probably too much
like you're allowed to say that and no
one's gonna cry about it the only
difference is that if you dare say it
about video games
people start crying um which only shows
how right the point is and how necessary
it is to say it
because people take it way too seriously
and are way too attached
number three before the national anthem
was played at a wnba game this weekend
the players walked off the court in
protest here's the footage of that
anthem was played we saw the players
leave the floor go back to their
respective locker rooms
one of those actions we'll see
throughout the season as part of the
social justice
initiative yeah first of many ways that
we will see wnba plays
players using their voices all season
long this is nothing new for these women
they have been proactive when it comes
to speaking out on social injustices for
the life of the wnba
now as i understand it three of their
viewers were very upset
um and said they're not going to watch
anymore that's what i read so the wnba
just lost
lost half of their audience which is
which is a pretty steep
loss there pretty devastating i guess
you could say that this move
was not exactly a slam dunk mostly
because the players can't touch the rim
but the really interesting thing is that
you know watching
that clip for most of us is the first
footage we've seen of a wnba game so at
least it confirms that the wnba exists
you know it's not a myth after all it
really is a thing apparently
i don't know why it exists but it does
uh it's just out there
you know if if women are playing
basketball in a forest
and nobody watches does it did it really
happen
you know that's been one of the
philosophical one of the great
philosophical conundrums apparently yeah
it did happen incredible number four
here's something uh we're starting to
see more of a political reporter posted
images from new zealand
showing that new zealand is basically
back to normal after covid and putting
them
in and putting new zealand forth as a
success story due to their lockdown
policies and contrasting
oh look how well new zealand is doing in
you know the united states
look how poorly they're doing um and
then a doctor mike galsworthy followed
up with his own post saying
no masks shaking hands bustling crowds
fully open economy
new zealand earned this by locking down
early and hard pursuing a zero coveted
strategy
libertarians would love to be in this
position but they are their own worst
enemies in a pandemic
now we're in a mess now i bring this up
just to show you how dishonest our
discourse has become
if you need it any more convincing
they're using new zealand
as an example crediting new zealand's
success with its policies
meanwhile new zealand is one of the most
remote
populated land masses on earth the
entire nation has a population the size
of los angeles's
um it gets only about four million
tourists a year to the entire country
compared to 80 million for the u.s it's
an
island its neighbor to the west is
australia 2 500 miles away and australia
is one of the most sparsely populated
countries in the world
and its neighbor to the south is
antarctica
so you've got a an island nation way out
there
um the furthest possible distance
you know for in relation to many other
countries and surrounded by ocean
if you go south you're in an arctic
wasteland
where the population is zero besides you
know whatever five or six scientists
living and living in
in you know research labs and then if
you go if you go
2500 miles to the west you run into
australia where you know it's like
there's people living around the coast
and just
nobody in the middle of that country at
all so
yeah i think probably that has a lot to
do with them
doing well in the pandemic new zealand
is going to do well in a global pandemic
literally no matter what its policies
are it doesn't matter
they're going to do well because they're
so isolated obviously okay number five
finally uh representative john lewis's
body
uh john you know john lewis obviously
died uh i guess it was
over a week ago now uh or last week
several days
he was taken across so his his body was
taken across the selma bridge yesterday
um
the time says as as
but here's the phrase take it across the
selma bridge
as remembrances continue
continue being the operative phrase
there there have been a lot of
remembrances of john lewis
there was a memorial service at brown
chapel ame church
in alabama then another memorial service
at troy university in alabama
and then at some point his body was
ceremonially ceremonially brought across
the bridge in a horse-drawn carriage
with an audience watching
then his bo bro then he was brought up
to dc to lion state for two days so the
public can pay respects
um then he'll be brought to atlanta
for memorial and then the following day
will be the funeral
okay so that's what three four memorial
services
plus a couple other ceremonial things
and then the you know
body on display public and pay respects
then a funeral
all of this is happening while thousands
of americans have not been allowed to
to have funerals for their own dead
relatives because of covid
so just imagine i mean maybe you don't
have to imagine maybe you're in this
position
i imagine someone
who was not able to have a funeral
service
for their father who passed away was not
even even able to gather
20 people in a chapel for a funeral
service
because they were told it's too
dangerous and yet now they turn on the
news
and see a politician has died and has
multiple funerals and memorials attended
by thousands of people across three
states
now if the funerals if the reason we're
not having a funeral service
for joe smith who dies down the street
if the reason his family can't gather to
mourn him is because it's not safe
then it doesn't suddenly become safe
when a prominent politician dies
either it's safe or it isn't either you
can do it safely or you can't
if you can't do it safely then we
shouldn't be doing it for john lewis
if you can do it safely then there's no
reason why we can't do it for joe smith
this is obviously pretty clear-cut i
would say
now i don't have a problem
in normal circumstances with with this
sort of thing when a prominent
uh politician or dignitary dies and and
we have all the memorial services i
don't have an issue with that
you know um i know there are some people
that always raise
issues with it because they say ours is
you know idolatry or whatever
i don't see it that way i think that
this is this is just what people do
when when when the prominent among them
pass away
and that's fine i got no issue with it
um
but i do have an issue with it if we're
doing it
while also telling normal americans that
they're not allowed to
gather and celebrate the lives of you
know their grandparents and parents and
others
who pass away that that is just
that is a outrageous example
of elitism and you know rule
rules for the but not for me type of
thing hey you
uh yeah you you're right you right there
hit the subscribe button right now
do it do it right now i thank you for
your compliance
it's somewhat appreciated